okay fine yes you can come yes as your
representative as my associate same
thing no it is not I have been Michaels
number to a guy for about five years and
we make a great team
I would like one of those classic famous
teams he's like Mozart and I'm like
Mozart's friend no I'm like Butch
Cassidy and Michael is like Mozart you
try and hurt Mozart you're gonna get a
bullet in your head
courtesy of Butch Cassidy because
corporate uh wants somebody to be here
on Saturday and so we're gonna have to
have a couple people come in on the
weekends and I know nobody's gonna want
to do it never buddy's gonna flame and
[ __ ] I don't want to have to deal with
that and that's what you have an
assistant regional manager
yes it is assistant to the regional
manager same thing no it's not it's
lower so it's close my eye come on I
need to talk you about the downsizing
there's no downsizing oh but if there
were I'd be protected as assistant
regional manager to the regional manager
yeah I am now senpai which is assistant
sensei assistant to the sensei that's
pretty cool assistant sensei okay I have
been testing you the entire day did you
know that of course and I'm happy to say
that you passed so effective immediately
I am promoting you from assistant to the
regional manager to assistant regional
manager Michael I don't know I know I
know I know I know I wouldn't be
offering it if I didn't think you could
handle it I can handle it I can okay so
I guess this will just be my office
no no Idol change only enough Pam sent
out a memo no no three month
probationary period let's just not tell
anybody about this right now just a
formality absolutely but not really uh
hello this is Dwight Schrute calling for
jan levinson-gould
this is Jan hi Dwight Schrute calling
acting manager Scranton branch listen I
needed your permission to fire Jim
Halpert Dwight Schrute from sales
well where's Michael Scott he is not
here right now he put me in charge of
the office listen to me very carefully
you are not a manager of anything
understand that's not entirely true
because he put me in charge of picking
the health care plan really yeah okay
when Michael gets back you tell him to
call me immediately call you immediately
good oh hey listen
um since I have you on the phone can i
fire Jim no all right Dwight as you know
I'm heading to New York today doing a
presentation on the bridge to the new
CFO and you want me to come with you
nope
opposite of that I will stay here and
run things on this end
okay good since you did such a good job
with the investigation I decided to pull
a few strings call in a few favors
and I've decided to make you official
security supervisor of the branch really
yes sir that's fantastic because I've
always felt that the security here
sucked so you want
Dwight K Schrute now hereby declare you
an honorary volunteer corporal in charge
of assisting all activities security
here's your badge thank you Michael
very nice great can I have a gun
no I don't have a gun all right hello I
don't believe we've been introduced
Dwight Schrute assistant regional
manager Andy Bernard regional director
in charge of sales so you'll be
reporting to me then on the contrary my
title has manager in it and I'm a
director which on a film set is the
highest title there is do you know
anything about film I know everything
about film I've seen over 240 of them
congratulations
one of my life goals was to die right
here in my desk chair and today that
dream was shattered oh what's this that
has been merit Jim Halpert tardiness
oh I love it already you've got to learn
Jim you are second in command but that
does not put you above the law oh I
understand and I also have lots of
questions like what does it demerit mean
let's put it this way you do not want to
receive three of those I had on me three
demerits and you'll receive a citation
now that sounds serious
oh it is serious five citations and
you're looking at a violation four of
those and you'll receive a verbal
warning keep it up and you're looking at
a written warning
two of those that'll land you in a world
of hurt in the form of a disciplinary
review written up by me and placed on
the desk of my immediate superior which
would be me that is correct okay I want
to copy on my desk by the end of the day
or you will receive a full desaturation
what's a distant what's that
oh you don't want to know
nothing to worry about just using the
scope Safety's on Joe is coming later
today I cannot have a subordinate trying
to make me look stupid okay I need you
to promise me that you'll be on your
best behavior I promise other people
that I'd be on my worst behavior and I
gave my word so don't make me fire you
you can't fire me
you're acting manager not office manager
so you have no firing powers
don't make me pre fire you you wouldn't
dare
watch this your pre fired and when I'm
promoted you'll be full fired if you get
promoted and if you haven't fallen in
love with me by then what I wanted to
see me yes the time has come to name my
own replacement so please hand this
letter of congratulations to Dwight K
Schrute but that's my name
Dwight congratulations a wipe don't
screw the pooch
okay okay play my game again second life
is not a game it is a multi-user virtual
environment it doesn't have points or
scores it doesn't have winners or losers
oh it as losers I signed up for a second
life about a year ago back then my life
was so great that I literally wanted a
second one in my second life I was also
a paper salesman and I was also named
white absolutely everything was the same
except I could fly little girl okay
people listen everybody fraud was
committed to out announcement I'm I was
making it everybody David Wallace and I
have talked and we have decided to
promote Jim to the position of co
manager told manager one of your butt
and your butt and your butt and you were
about all of Scranton branch butts
what's happening to you Michael what's
happening to me I am also being promoted
to co-manager we will be co managers
together Jim Halpert welcome thank you
I will be leaving tomorrow
yes so I wanted to give you that it's a
letter of recommendation
this could be good to whom it may
concern
good real personal things Michael the
dictionary defines superlative as of the
highest kind quality or order surpassing
all else or others supreme that's great
if I wanted the dictionary definition
and buy a dictionary I define it as
Dwight Schrute as a sales executive as a
leader as a man and as a friend he is of
the highest kind quality and order
supreme
lots more like that
you